hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back
they lied to you all this time you
thought you knew the truth
but you don't
these pictures
changed altered manipulated
all to hide the truth
my neck is so much thicker than this
and you will help me to reveal
the truth
all right so here's the deal i got a
youtubes coming out this friday on the
28th and i can't do a normal promo to
save my life so
if you want to win one of these bad boys
all you got to do is
edit a photo of mine back to its
original thick
neck state just make it as thick as you
want as thick as possible
make a meme out of it make some art i
don't really care just post it on my
subreddit and
i'll pick a winner and give you one of
these i'll sign it too just make sure
you get the thickness of my neck correct
or they'll be hell to pay and if you
don't feel like making anything how dare
you you can still enter a giveaway by
going to markiplier.youtubes.com
that's markiplier.youtubes.com link
in the description all right uh back to
whatever you were watching
probably my video i hope this is on my
video if i managed to get this into
another channel that'd be something
minecraft today
i'm going to be messing with redstone
i have a ton of it actually i don't know
if i have a ton of it but i have a lot
of it and look how good i look in my
diamond
armor really really good anyway so what
i want to do is i want to be able to
make a mine
cart that's going to take me down into
the mine so i don't have to deal with
jumping into a pit of water which
probably hurts
but i'm tough so i guess it doesn't
really bother me but i'm going to
be experimenting with rails and such and
buttons and whatnot
so i have to um do that this is the kind
of stuff that allows people to
make a computer that can play minecraft
inside of minecraft
so if i can figure out how to do that
i'll make a shield yeah sure why not i'm
a little
off topic but i'll do it yeah yeah rail
detector rail
stone pressure plate interesting
activator rail
redstone torch i need redstone torch
block of redstone i could make that for
whatever reason i would need that
cauldron i don't know why that's a thing
but i'll make that i haven't seen that
before
powered rail gold that's why you need
gold that's why you need gold
horse horse armor wait can i just make
then no
you in this round a mine cart i'm gonna
need that
i'm gonna definitely need that smithing
table i still don't know why that's a
thing
a compass i made my first redstone thing
i made a compass
i'm amazing soul can't fall
okay redstone torch let's assume i need
a lot of those
or some of those or not a lot of those
i'm gonna make 20 of those so where's
this
mysterious rail i've heard so much about
rail activator rail powered rail
detector rail
what about just regular old rail what
what about
rail what about just rail what about
rail
i guess i have to make powered rail but
that doesn't make sense
but if where were you
i just looked free fine this is fine
64 rail holy hell uh powered rail
that's what i need let's make some of
those
24 okay so we got 24 of those we got 64
of those i'm thinking we're gonna need
more of those
boom love it by the way i love that
okay but i'm gonna need a button too
button a button you
say hmm what about an iron button can't
make an iron button
just gotta make a wood button i know
button does to the
the the the redstone it makes the
redstone go
how did i do that oh yeah
oh my god that's so cool that's
delightful
i did not know that you can click and
drag in it oh well that's lovely
it's night now they're not gonna get me
i still don't know if the whole illager
thing is gonna be a problem or if i'm
gonna have to
do something about that anyway so i
first i need a way into my
mind that's not gonna be dumb so i need
to make a direction that's not gonna be
stupid
which way would be the least dumb
this way i'm gonna enchant i'm gonna
make a diamond
shovel why because no one's allowed to
stop me
it's not a waste of resources if i
actually use it and i enjoy using it and
you know what else i'm gonna do
i'm gonna enchant this and no one can
stop
me because i can do whatever i want in
minecraft
efficiency 4 that sounds awesome i want
that can i have that
i want efficiency
[Music]
unbreaking it shall be my what
oh we got efficiency too ooh all right
cool good hey
i knew that was gonna happen oh smithing
table what do i do with you
okay um you go here
boink up
how do i do that how do i do how
i will kill you wait
no i will kill you
wow that really is the bane of
arthropods
all right so i got the rail i don't need
the gold i need to accomplish
oh i just need that on my inventory
although that's nice
well that's really nice okay like i said
i'm gonna make it go a non-stupid
direction and i pick that as this
i think that you make rail by going in a
straight diagonal right i guess i should
run a test
first that would be very smart all right
here we go this is gonna be it
this is the one okay this is it we're
going down
down in the middle around we're going
down
we did it all right so that's good to
know that that definitely worked that
worked 100
that worked great nothing i need to ever
worry about that ever again
man who knew that minecraft was gonna
have so much digging
there's a lot of digging holes so the
objective here is to save me
time into getting down into a hole
that's
legitimately the main reason but it's
also
good because it's fun
it's fun i don't need to justify it any
further than that
do you like how i spent all that time in
the last episode farming up experience
so that i could get to the level 30
enchantment
and then i never once actually use the
level 30
enchantment i don't enchant anything
with it whereas i just do everything
level 15.
i just realized that i did that and
that's really
that's so cool of me that i did that not
frustrating at all
hey look at this look at that we made it
somewhere
all right i think actually this is
exactly where we want to be this kind of
level this is great
because i think this is probably the
exact level of of of uh you know where i
need to be
this is oh this is awesome this is
perfect i really picked the right
direction
excellent i i'm gonna die here
i'm so going into the lava i will never
have the coordination to get this
accomplished
okay wow that's a big lava river
why so girthy why so incredibly girthy
aye you jerkwad you're lucky you're not
an arthropod
or else i would smoke hey how you doing
hey good to see you um okay hey
oh this is not the point the the point
is not that i'm gonna
be mining here yet this is a great base
this is a perfect spot
to have this i'm very lucky that this is
here
but i will explore it in a moment
because i'm experimenting
with redstone not necessarily an
experiment i know exactly what i'm doing
i think i just put it here
i've never built a working railroad
before in my life okay i really don't
know uh what needs to be powered i don't
know
what to do for design um i'm just gonna
hope that i don't
smash my head on the roof and um yeah
that
this uh this seems good but oh it's
night time oh this is a problem for
tomorrow
i need another freaking box can i have
my wheat i need to feed my cows
hair momos momos moomoos
moomies muse mumeos
moomoos moomamumu's good job oh
good work there excellent work ethic
mumus
look at a look at those babies oh god
then some good babies
all right that's horrifying all right
cool good now time for a good night's
sleep
i really deserve it so now that we got a
fresh day ahead of us
now we can discover what it is to go
further beyond
as soon as i make another box and
deposit all the crap that i have because
i have too much crap
the link ah this cauldron what do i do
with a cauldron what what is th
what is a cauldron all about what do i
do what do i do what do i do with you
i'll figure it out later it's not the
point i'm figuring out rail
right now okay rail mine cart
if i go down there i go down there but
how would i get back up
i need powered rail where'd my redstone
torches go
there give and redstone you there
you there okay i'll get this just to say
everybody
hold on okay so redstone there
get rid of that that and carve this out
a little bit redstone there
button there i put yeah okay
that does that maybe i can put the
button
right there yeah okay then i put this
i make this powered
okay i get in shooty uh
not yet there really i can't put
i can't put it on really really
fine okay
okay fine sure okay fine
okay what
is that okay that worked
that didn't do anything to that okay
whatever it worked so if i get in
okay why is it not going okay
okay is it because it's on a lifted
platform
if i just okay oh
uh that no no no oh
my god
okay all right that's fine that's fine
all i need to do to get back up is
power another one can i make a
cobblestone
okay button redstone
don't work that way oh it works that way
okay
minecart here back it up a bit back it
up pick it up pick it up
get in push go
okay i wasn't pushing forward
[Music]
all right i need another booster
halfway up because i i need more boost
to get going
right right right
i need the rail pressure plate
because it's not getting a signal here
to activate i need the pressure plate
rail which is going to activate that as
i go
up and therefore is going to activate it
and then
send me further boosted back up uh-huh
yeah this is the way
i get it now i am smart
i am the detector rail i need a stone
pressure plate how do i make a stone
pressure plate
right pressure pressure
you put stone you
you you you you
you you think you can meet me
be the smart you maybe i just need a
heavy weighted pressure plate
the mine cart is very heavy and i'm in
the mine cart
you are not what you'd say you are
you think that you can fool me
i don't think
that you can fool me you
think that you know what you
are but you don't know you'll never know
you never know anything about anything
because you don't know what the truth is
but i know i know the truth
i'm gonna put water in the crucible
i'll put water in that's the answer
yes this is the way i put the water in i
take the water out
i put the water in i take the water out
i put the water in and i'm
[Music]
i'm okay so i need stone that's what i
need
how do i get stuff i have andesite
is that what i need polished andesite
why oh what if i
ah damn it okay maybe there's a way to
turn
can i
[Music]
oh is that gonna make hey
stop
oh look at all my new oh okay
that makes sense that makes sense
and then you can make the detector rail
and then you raid what is that what what
what what uh wait wait
stop what
does that mean
hey hey hey hey you you will die you
will die you will die
you will die you you will die you you
will die
your stupid hat i will claim it for my
own now
you yeah oh no your hat is
mine die
you don't even hurt me my enchanted
armor is too strong for you
oh no you're all dead thanks for the exp
nerds what raid again what do you mean
raid again what do you mean
oh they're fighting over there oh i will
help you
i will help you
oh ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding hello oh yeah
oh another banner for my collection
yeah bling blong yeah there's a problem
yeah there's a yeah
no don't cry
[Music]
what the heck is that thing
i will kill you give me your experience
oh my goodness oh you're tough okay
you're actually tough
good thing i have armor ow now
okay actually you're kind of tall i'm
going to run away i'm going to kill this
stupid hat guy
your hat is dumb
hey uh listen i need to eat a pork chop
steak sorry steak
it's a steak no look at my oh well my
boxes oh my god oh please oh my god
please
don't villagers help me golems help me
oh my god that is so scary that is
terrifying
help help me help
help big monster alert yeah i got get it
yeah get it yeah oh yeah
oh stupid oh there's more i am working
with redstone right now
not raidstone i'm gonna feed my cows and
not even worry about you
cause you're you're in my crops
oh oh they got witches oh no hey
wow
man you guys are chumps bunch of jumpers
you
trampled my crops you astronauts
let's see and censor that oh
wow that's a lot of you okay experience
for me
oh god the big thing is not supposed to
ah help
help help extractor ex
oh my god it's all the things from
minecraft dungeons help
i hope you all are very tough and i am
so wimpy
i am wimpy oh my god you hurt so bad
oh my god
you are alone and i shall kill you
oh oh ow do their golems all die oh no
is it just me oh no their golems are
over here what are you looking at the
flowers for
what are you admiring my farm for
there's business
wow oh my god
oh i almost died oh my god
oh wow
[Music]
i am the hero i saved them all
i alone stood between death and
destruction
i saved everyone yes i am also ah
i am humble watch as i
feed my cows like a hero would
yes thank you getting a little crowded
in there um
that's probably fine well at least i got
some more banners
no oh no it will come bothering me now
now that i got the heads of all their
leaders strewn up on my
cows that's a nightmare of mooing
um gotta say that's that's really
something awful
hey don't trample my crops please uh
okay yeah redstone right i was in the
middle of that
minecart is there i need to
make a couple probably a couple
sections of maybe three
four four sections of this
with a detector rail and when i go over
that
it will detect and it will activate
those
that's what i'm assuming the detector
rail does not a hundred percent sure
but that seems like what it would do
and then that yeah right but yeah
yeah this is definitely it detect okay
all right i'm thinking that this is
exactly what i needed
this is exactly what the doctor ordered
what does that emerald think
am i gonna get a reward should i go to
the villagers and try to get a reward
out of them should i extort them
say hey maybe i won't be here next time
hey maybe you should be a little
grateful to me huh
maybe you should do that huh you ever
think about that no i bet you didn't
anyway hi do you have my reward
may i have my reward okay
quiet uh just uh leave the reward in one
of my boxes i'll come get it later the
freaking weirdos
man if i didn't have diamond armor on
that i would have died so fast
how's my armor doing oh no uh
can i help you uh yes it is me the hero
of the village
i am a hero thank you for noticing also
i'm a
redstone genius if you didn't notice
that please watch out just stay off the
tracks it's very dangerous
[Music]
we
okay it's not meant to go that way i
will this is what it's meant to do
[Music]
i don't have redstone down that's why
because there's nothing for it to
activate
right that makes sense redstone
redstone redstone that makes sense
that's what it needs
it would need that all it is is a
pressure plate it's not actually
there's no that makes sense all right
let's do this
let's do this again
saw the redstone light up i saw the it
lit
it lit up it lit up it lit
it lights off
i put the lava in the bucket i put the
lava in the bucket i put it in the hole
i put it in though
it goes in the bucket in the hole in the
bucket in the ho
what about the torch
okay okay okay okay
oh we don't need the switch because
if it's always powered then there's no
problem that's what this is for
i see the truth for what it really is oh
we don't need the redstone at all
we needed a torch yeah i would think
that if it it lit up the redstone it
would have worked but you know
we're gonna ignore that for now i didn't
even need to dig these holes i could
just put it on the wall
i could just put it on the wall
okay now we have this
now we've got this and even still
i get the button but yes
all right cool good
what did you just put in my cauldron did
you just sh
what's the incentive did you just poop
in my cauldron
uh i don't have any leather at the
moment
hang on one second just hold on one
second one second
these distractions are great i am trying
to do
redstone
i make so many cows
oh my goodness bruh
bruh bruh bruh bruh
i have 60 leather
i have 60 leather okay wait i'm gonna
get one
i'm gonna get one where'd you go
he's gone okay well uh now i have golems
defending my house which is
awesome um but not really the
the objective of this video i'll make
some books
i'll make some paper and i'll make some
more books
and i'll make some bookshelves i
need more wood okay guys um
this has been a weird little bit of
weird adventure today
i think that's all the time i got for
this episode i smear redstone's still a
mystery
my railroad has still not really worked
but
hey i've got golem friends and i'm a
hero of the village and i have banners
and the heads of my enemies on pikes and
i've got more cows than i know what to
do with
so that's all good i think thank you
everybody so much for watching
let me know what you think down in the
comments below and as always
i will see you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye
bye